the first step to becoming a polyglot is
to learn one more language hi there
steve coffin here and today i want to
talk about how to become a polyglot
now remember if you enjoy these videos
please subscribe click on the bell for
notifications if you follow me on a
podcast service
please leave a review i do appreciate it
so
how do we become
polyglots now the reason i'm talking
about this is
because
my wife and i were playing uh golf the
other day at our golf club with a couple
uh probably in their 60s
and often you you know you're you're
teamed up with people you don't know
this was our first chance to meet this
couple and
they told us they were going on a
bicycle trip with their friends eight
couples going to hirona in spain
uh to
bicycle around in catalunya
so i said are you going to learn
catalan or spanish of course i was going
to push link you know
so which i did of course but to no avail
uh and so i said are you going to learn
catalan or spanish
or spanish and the answer was well i've
heard that you can get by with english
all right
true enough perhaps maybe maybe not i
don't know in the city of hirono
uh certainly at the hotel in the
restaurants you can get by in the shops
with english
um
outside of video i don't know i i think
if you're in a little town and you get a
flat tire and you're in trouble maybe
english is not so common i simply i just
don't know but
for me if i were going on a bicycle trip
to catalunya i would learn catalan now i
speak spanish but so i have the
mentality of a polyglot to me that would
be fun
fun to explore
catalan if i learned catalan i would
read books about catalunya in catalan i
would speak to people in catalan
i that gives me a great sense of
pleasure i feel that i'm enriching my
life by learning another language
connecting with people in their language
i have the mentality of a polyglot
i tweeted about this
and i call this the english language
disease that english speakers
they have the option or they think they
have the option of not learning the
language because we can get by in
english
and and
most of the responses to my tweet were
very um
much in agreement gee that's too bad
blah blah blah but one fellow from
england or maybe he was somewhere else
but
his his description showed that he's
from manchester says where i live there
was just a portuguese person showing a
danish person around our compound and
they were speaking english that's just
the reality that's how it works too bad
so that person also doesn't have the
mentality of a polyglot
so
number one to become a polyglot you have
to want to become a polyglot you have to
like speaking languages not just one but
several so that is a mindset okay
the second thing is
you know i didn't set out to become a
polyglot i had not really heard the term
polyglot in english to me a linguist was
someone who spoke several languages
but i also didn't set out to become a
linguist i got interested in french and
then i had the opportunity to learn
mandarin
and then i was in japan so i learned
japanese on my own
and stepping back when i was in france i
would hitchhike around in europe and i
would always try to speak a local
language so
i think what i find what i think is
useful to note there is
that the first step to becoming a
polyglot is to learn one more language
okay because for people who have never
really acquired fluency in another
language who have never converted
themselves into a fluent speaker of
another language
they don't have that feeling so that you
can't sort of
skip past the stage of learning one
language to become a polyglot you learn
one language you now feel confident that
you can learn languages
you enjoy the process or maybe you don't
um
i think if you do it the right way you
can enjoy it
and then what happened to me and i think
what would happen to a lot of people is
you know gee i learned one language now
i'd like to learn another language
because the experience of speaking
another language of connecting with
people in their language is so rewarding
that we want to do it again and again
and that sense of satisfaction that
actually we were able to succeed in in
this task which is not such an easy task
but that sense of satisfaction makes us
want to do it again
now another thing about becoming a
polyglot in my opinion is
we shouldn't be afraid obviously when we
go from language now b to language c in
the language d
that means that we aren't spending time
on language b
so we're leaving language b because i
firmly believe we never master another
language we can always improve in that
other language and yet we make the
decision i'm not going to
become even better let's say my best
foreign language is french so i'm not
going to become even better in french
or let's say that the next language is
japanese and i know there are great gaps
in my japanese learning okay i'm not
going to work on becoming even better in
japanese
i'm going to go and explore a new
language so there's a choice there you
sacrifice sort of what i would consider
the futile pursuit of perfection not
other people can disagree and they want
to pursue perfection that's fine i'm not
sort of making any value judgments but i
think to be a polyglot is different than
trying to become perfect in one language
so we accept the fact that we're going
to not be as good in some of the
languages that we have learned
we even accept the fact that there's
going to be interference
not only from our own languages which is
always the case but there's going to be
interference from these languages that
we have learned in the new languages
that we are trying to learn because i
find myself sometimes when i'm searching
for words
in russian the other day i hadn't spoken
russian for a long time and i'm speaking
russian i'm searching for words and up
comes persian so the more languages you
have in your head bouncing around
as your
brain is going down different pathways
to find words the greater likelihood is
that it's going to go into
some rabbit hole as they say
uh where you're into an yet another
language so i think part of becoming a
polyglot is accepting that you're going
to be less than perfect that means
you're going to speak with mistakes your
pronunciation may not be perfect
but you have this this
sense of achievement of this and the the
intellectual stimulus of discovering a
new world
yet another new world with all of the
people and and as you learn another
language then the people of that
language come alive the history comes
alive and so i think the secret to being
a polyglot is to be interested in
many different languages and cultures
it may be that some people are motivated
to
learn languages in order to
demonstrate that they they're able to
learn languages and you know like
another notch on my belt i only have
eight languages now i have nine
and that can also be a valid um you know
motivation for becoming a polyglot just
to demonstrate your prowess at learning
languages
i wonder if that can sustain you though
because
if all you want to do is show off look i
can say a few things in this other
language that
doesn't take a lot of of time and effort
and you can get to where you can say
hello how are you in many different
languages
and
that too is fun i'm not criticizing that
but
insofar as my own motivation as a
polyglot if you look at my experience
now with persian and arabic which are my
19th and 20th languages i've been at
them for more than two years
it's not uh it's not like three months
and uh and i'm continuing to discover
new things about those languages and
those cultures
and i do want to get back to turkish
and i hear that we have we may have our
link mini stories done up in urdu in
which case once we get link 5.0 launched
we will add urdu and then i would like
to get into urdu as my approach into the
south asian languages because then
because i'm a bit lazy at learning new
writing systems
then i won't have to you know learn
either hindi or punjabi writing systems
and i'll still be able to get
some sense of
the sounds of of those languages i may
still end up learning the writing system
we'll see
but
you know this again as a polyglot
i have this tremendous world of
languages to look forward to and i don't
know which languages i'm going to
explore in the future
[Music]
i think we'll have tagalog we'll have
vietnamese that link thai maybe
maybe indonesia maybe swahili something
on the african continent i don't know
but as a polyglot my motivation is is to
get in there and explore these but i
recognize that each and every one of
them is going to be a lot of work
but enjoyable
and but for me that's fine that's what i
have to look forward to so
perhaps that's my perspective on how to
become a polyglot
but to summarize you have to be
motivated to learn languages you have to
be interested in learning these
languages you have to be interested in a
particular language you learn them one
at a time and as you achieve success in
one language you may find that you're
motivated to learn another language you
have to be
you know unafraid of interference from
languages that
you have previously learned you have to
be unafraid of the fact that some of the
languages that you have learned will
actually
get very very rusty you may in fact not
be able to speak in that language like
if you were to ask me now to speak in
romanian or greek i would i wouldn't be
able to do it and yet i know that i have
learned those languages to a level where
i went to the country and i was able to
communicate and that's okay because i
can't
you know if you have 20 pots on a stove
it's very difficult to keep them all you
know simmering without burning any one
of them or without the fire going out
here and there so that's fine so all of
those things i think
uh are part of the the um you know at
least in my case the attitude of a
polyglot i can't speak for other
polyglots
so there you have it how to become a
polyglot i hope you enjoyed it thank you
for listening bye for now